hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast antimicrobial stewardship its
role in managing antibiotic resistance
presented by dr. Haley Avenue research
health scientist Providence VA Medical
Center I mix a tributary of lab roots
and I will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. a Peniel I will
now turn the presentation over to her
thank you for that introduction today
again I'm gonna be talking about
antibiotic stewardship and this is a
topic I am very passionate about
antibiotic stewardship and its role in
managing antibiotic resistance so this
presentation is in my view and not the
view of the VA as a whole and I have no
conflicts to disclose today again I'm
going to talk about the importance of
antibiotic stewardship identified some
antibiotic resistant pathogens the ones
we are most concerned about at this time
describe some current and emerging
antibiotic stewardship strategies for
target antibiotic resistance and then
assess some of the evidence out there
for antibiotic stewardship so first
we're going to start out and talk about
why antibiotic stewardship it is so
important and why we critically have a
need for antibiotic stewardship so
antibiotic resistance is one of the
world's most pressing problems at this
time infections that were once easily
treatable by antibiotics are now
becoming increasingly difficult to cure
and anytime we turn on the news we can
see evidence of this we hear stories
about superbugs and nightmare bacteria
those are our carbapenem resistant
enterobacter ACA or cre now we hear how
this world is running out of antibiotics
how antibiotic resistance is costing us
billions of dollars a year in excess
healthcare costs so antibiotic
resistance really is a huge burden so I
wanted to start out and get you guys
thinking at home and ask you a question
you can answer this to yourself by one
to get idea of what you've got the
problem with antibiotic resistance was
so how many people in the United States
you think develop an infection due to in
antibiotic resistant bacteria every year
50,000 a hundred thousand five hundred
thousand 1 million or two million so for
those of you that said 2 million you are
correct on the CDC estimated that in
2013 there are at least 2 million
illnesses and 23,000 deaths every year
that current due to antibiotic resistant
bacteria this is a minimum and with Dana
done in 2013 so it is likely an
underestimate as well so any discussion
on antibiotic stewardship must begin
with acknowledging how powerful
antibiotics are antibiotics really
enabled modern modern medicine as we
know it and the Bell
antibiotics is argumento most important
advance in modern medicine at this time
the ability to cure infections that were
once untreatable happened when
antibiotics were developed and they
enabled critical care medicine complex
surgeries organ transplantation and
cancer chemotherapy and it is estimated
that the deaths in the United States
declined by 220 per 100,000 in the 15
years since the development of
sulfonamide than penicillin much more
than any other medical technology we've
had so conservative estimates about the
absolute reduction in death media by
mediated by antibiotics is quite
remarkable community acquired pneumonia
the death rate decreased about 25
percent between the pre-antibiotic
period and after antibiotics were
available commercially hospital acquired
pneumonia decreased 30% heart valve
infections and brain infections
decreasing 75 percent and 60% with a
mortality rate skin infections now are
very rarely associated with mortality
but before antibiotics they had a death
rate of about 10 percent so an absolute
reduction of about 10 percent alright so
in 2014
Jim O'Neill who was economists was
commissioned by the British government
to release this report which estimated
the current death toll of antibiotic
resistance worldwide and that was at
700,000 and also he estimated that if
resistance were allowed to grow
unchecked if there were no successful
efforts to curb antibiotic resistance or
no new drugs developed that the death
toll would rise to 10 million by 2050
which is just 30 years from now when
that's more than currently die from
cancer and diabetes put together
additionally he showed that
the deaths tribunal two animatic
resistance would fall unevenly across
the world so Africa and Asia would
suffer some of the greatest losses with
four million deaths in each of those
countries at this time I mean sorry by
2050 also it must be noted that our
problem with the resistance is not only
exacerbated by overuse in humans but
also in u.s. livestock so in animals in
the United States consume more than
twice as many medically important
antibiotics as humans so not only do we
need to focus on efforts to improve our
use in human but animals as well even
though that will not be the focus of
this talk so now that we talked about
just why antibiotic stewardship is so
important I will now move on to some of
our biggest concerns with regards to
antibiotic resistance so in 2009 the
infectious diseases Society of America
released this publication bad bugs no
drugs and this was really to call
attention to the crisis of antibiotic
resistance and call for the development
of new antibiotics especially for these
six resistant organisms that were
increasingly escaping the effects of
antibiotics so they became known as the
pathogens and they are our grand
positives Enterococcus faecium
Staphylococcus aureus and then gram
negatives Klebsiella pneumoniae
Acinetobacter a Pseudomonas and
enterobacter species and then in 2013
the CDC published this report called
antibiotic resistant threats in the
United States and this outlines the top
18 drugs resistant threat in the United
States at this time and these are
threats because they are resistant to
our first line in our second line
antibiotic treatment options and
sometimes even there are no commercially
available options to treat these
infections so health care providers are
forced to use antibiotics that may be
more toxic
more expensive and less effective than
other agents and even when there are
treatment options available data has
shown that patients with resistant
infections are much more likely to defy
to die have higher morbidity and
mortality have longer healthcare stays
in the hospital and have delayed the
cooporation time so it is critically
important for the public health to
implement strategies to improve the way
we use antibiotics in this report the
CDC categorized bacteria into three
levels of threat that was urgent
for example our carpet and resistant
enterobacter ACA serious multiple
drug-resistant Pseudomonas are Ginoza
and extended spectrum beta-lactamase
producing enter back duration a for
example and then the lowest level was
concerning Oh Sita is one of the urgent
threats Sita
causes like threatening diarrhoea it can
be so severe that may lead to
hospitalization and even death and these
infections are not really problem with
resistance like some of the other ones
but more antibiotic use just leads to
seed it so seated infections are the
primary driver is antibiotic use and
exposure to the healthcare system see
death causes about 500,000 infections
every year and 29,000 deaths at least
and causes millions and excess
healthcare costs each year when the CDC
report came out the estimate was that
caused 250,000 infections but a
subsequent report on 2015 showed that
burden is actually much higher at about
50,000 Rene tsa's of CF a year in the
United States so resistance again is
particularly a problem with our gram
negatives and
of gram negatives were given urgent and
serious level threats in this CDC report
in particular our espl producing
enterobacter ACA our CR ease
multidrug-resistant Pseudomonas and
multi-year aqua Sisseton Acinetobacter
all causing a number of infections and
deaths in the united states alert to the
CDC the world health organization
established priority levels for some of
our most concerning bacteria like the
CDC they gave Acinetobacter B money
Pseudomonas and director ACA are penned
and resistant in our ESP o resistant
enter back duration a high levels of
threat they put all of these in the
critical level which was their highest
level of threat so antibiotic resistance
is now an international agenda in May
2017 the g20 nations met and put this
into microbial resistance international
agenda document together and they called
for three strategies to combat this
crisis of antibiotic resistance and that
was promoting conservation of
antimicrobials optimizing use and
investing in technologies to bring new
antibiotics and Diagnostics to the
market so antibiotic use directly leads
to antibiotic resistance it's widely
known that inappropriate use leads to
antibiotic resistance but appropriate
use often is less often cited as a cause
of antibiotic resistance there was a
survey that was done in 2002 and greater
than 90% of respondents these were
medical residents I believe they cited
inappropriate use as a cause of
resistance but they were much less
likely to cite appropriate use of the
cause of resistance so even if all
inappropriate use were eliminated we
would still have Anna
persistent infections occur but they
would occur at a much lower frequency
and the problem is that we drastically
overuse our antibiotics in the United
States in worldwide it's estimated that
over 260 million courses of antibiotics
are prescribed every year in the United
States and that's five prescriptions
written for every six people and a
greater than 50% of patients who are
hospitalized receive at least one dose
of antibiotics so now just another
question - again
if you thinking what percent of
antibiotic use is inappropriate in the
United States that less than 10% 25% 50%
75% or 100% so you just think about that
and for those of you that said between
50 and 75 percent you are correct
it does vary based on the healthcare
setting but it's thought that at least
30 percent is inappropriate in
outpatient settings 50 percent in acute
care settings with even higher rates in
certain areas such as the ICU and in
long-term care settings at least 75
percent of antibiotic use is
inappropriate
so now we talked about antibiotic
stewardship and why it's important we
talked about some of the problems with
resistance and some are great path great
concerns
we'll talk about nasan strategies to
improve antibiotic use so in 2007 the
infectious diseases Society of America
released guidelines for antibiotic
stewardship in hospitals and antibiotic
stewardship is really the most important
strategy to improve our use of
antibiotics and again 2017 2007
guidelines were released for hospitals
and since that time antibiotic
stewardship has been recommended across
all healthcare settings including
long-term care facilities and outpatient
settings and 2016 updated guidelines for
stewardship were released and in both of
these guidelines antibiotic stewardship
is defined as coordinated interventions
to improve and measure the appropriate
use of antibiotics by promoting the
selection of optimal drug regimen dose
duration of therapy and route of
administration so you can think of it as
any strategy to improve the drug the
dose the duration even the diagnosis
making sure the patient actually has an
indication or an antibiotic and two main
strategies that are used are restriction
and prior authorization which is a
front-end approach where providers must
get authorization to use a certain
antibiotic and then there's also
prospective audit and feedback which is
a back-end program which is more what
our facility does and we review all
patients who are on antibiotics and then
we make recommendations every day to
improve the drug the dose duration we do
de-escalation to improve our antibiotic
treatment in our facility so there are a
number of different tools that can be
used to make sure that our patients are
getting the most appropriate treatment
when they are first started on
antibiotics we can have pathways and
order sets that we can be followed in
the emergency department to make sure
the correct antibiotics are chosen and
also to make sure the patient actually
has an indication for an antibiotic so
for example a lot of work has gone into
urinary tract infection treatment
pathways to make sure the patient
actually has urinary symptoms and has a
true UTI before we treat them to create
treatment pathways we need to use
national guidelines but also the local
antibiogram and an anti by agreeing is a
profile of antimicrobial susceptibility
tests to the pathogens that are most
common in the institution and common
antibacterial agents used to treat those
pathogens and this allows for
selection of antibiotic therapy within
an institution we also need to consider
patient risk factors for multi
drug-resistant organisms take cultures
and then appropriately follow up on
those cultures and de-escalate treatment
or stop treatment once the patient has
clinically improved so antibiotic
stewardship programs have been shown to
improve patient outcomes by reducing
unnecessary antibiotic prescriptions and
also they reduce the unintended
consequences of antibiotics such as
adverse drug events and toxicities also
decrease a difficile infections decrease
antibiotic resistance and also if you do
all of those things you will decrease
cost within the institution as well so
now I'm going to talk about two
strategies that are gaining more and
more evidence to support their use and
that is limiting the duration of therapy
to the shortest effective course and
then also I've talked a little bit about
rapid diagnostic testing so the history
behind antibiotic durations and using
extended durations of antibiotics dates
back to the 1940s at this time it was
recommended to administer penicillin to
patients with pneumonia until there was
definite clinical improvement in
temperature have remained below 100
Fahrenheit for 12 hours and then at that
point continued to treat for another two
to three days and the reason was this
for this was that they thought they
could prevent relapses by doing this and
this was based on a few case series
where the patients had short courses
they said they had relapses when they
went back and look to these reaction
Green infections with different
bacterial species so it is unclear how
this belief that antibiotic resistance
could be prevented by continuing therapy
on symptom present solution so
continuing the treatment for another two
to three days beyond the patient had
completely responded how that would
actually
resistance actually the opposite is true
extending directions do not prevent
resistance at all there's been no
evidence and about it use beyond the
point of symptom resolution reduces
antibiotic resistance studies have shown
that long courses of therapy result in
greater emergence of antibiotic
resistance for example there was a
randomized controlled trial and this
compared eight versus 15 days of therapy
for 200 patients with Ventrella
ventilator associated pneumonia and they
found between the two groups there was
no difference in recurrent infections
about 30% of patients had recurrent
infections in both groups both the short
and long course treatment but among
those who developed recurrent infections
less multi drug-resistant pathogens were
identified in those who received eight
days of therapy and quite a bit less to
42 percent in the group on the shorter
course of therapy and 62 percent in the
group on the longer course of therapy so
short of course therapy really is better
there was this article released in JAMA
internal medicine which reviewed a
number of the antibiotic trials
comparing shorter versus longer
durations of therapy for a variety of
acute bacterial infections and adults
and essentially what they showed was
that all trials studying this have found
that short course therapy is jeff's
effective as long course therapy for a
number of different infections such as
community partner monia hospital
pneumonia cellulitis COPD
for example excuse me
so there was also this meta-analysis in
May of 2008 and it studied clinical
trials comparing short versus long
courses of therapy for hospital in
patients with pneumonia complicated UTI
and draw abdominal infections and Nosek
all
infections of unknown organ origin and
across 13 trials that included efficacy
data in almost 3,000 patients they found
no difference in clinical care
microbiological cure mortality or
infection recurrence comparing short
versus long duration therapy so the next
thing we'll talk about our strategy is
rapid diagnostic testing rapid
diagnostic testing and stewardship are
linked so effective antibiotic
stewardship is closely linked with our
ability to make correct diagnosis
however antibiotics are rarely
prescribed based on a definitive
diagnosis most antibiotics are actually
prescribed based on an empiric diagnosis
where the provider will guess at whether
the patient actually has an infection or
not and then what might be causing the
infection so they're guessing whether
it's a bacterial versus a virus for
example for a respiratory infection and
then they are to have to guess at what
the most appropriate treatment is so
diagnostic tests can show whether or not
an antibiotic may be actually needed and
which one
however using our traditional methods
these often take a number of number of
days to get these results back and so
the patient has already been on
treatment or maybe even completed their
treatment at a time we get this
information back
so using traditional approaches tastes
at least 24 hours to obtain growth from
our clinical specimen and then usually
at least another 24 hours to isolate the
pathogen so typically it tastes at least
48 hours per pathogen pathogen
identification and then another 48 to 72
hours for our antibiotic susceptibility
test to come back so as a consequence
therapeutic decisions are commonly made
and peer eclis like I said before and
they're often started on very broad
spectrum treatment until more clinical
information becomes available so with
the emergence increase of resistant
organisms such as methicillin-resistant
Staphylococcus aureus our resistant gram
negatives such as ESP ELLs and
carbapenem ace resistant enter backdoor
ACA multi drug-resistant Pseudomonas
patients are often empirically started
on very broad treatment for example with
vancomycin and her personal and Tazo
back dam and continued on that treatment
for usually at least three days until we
have more information and the cultural
or the antibiotic susceptibility results
are back and we can narrow the patient's
treatment so if we had more rapid
testing we could significantly reduce
this time that patients are on these
broad-spectrum therapies and get our
patients on more appropriate treatment
quicker hmm rapid diagnostic testing
just in respiratory illnesses could
decrease the number of unnecessary
antibiotics prescribed annually guess
with respiratory infections just 27
million prescriptions could be avoided
just for that alone so rapid diagnostic
testing could have a huge impact in
improving the way we use an anti
microbials so a number of different
approaches are available for rapid
diagnostic testing in this is a growing
field which is actively getting
more and more technology daily and so
there are a number of approaches some of
these are culture dependent and some are
culture independent and thumb can be
used at the point of care and they can
be used in emergency department insights
use outpatient settings I'm not going to
go into the specifics of each of these
but know there are a number of different
technologies that are being developed
and we can more rapidly identify our
pathogens and resistant speeds and
determinants so the role of diagnostic
testing in stewardship it could help us
to identify pathogens to guide the
selection of the antibiotic agents that
we use to guide de-escalation from broad
spectrum to narrow spectrum treatment
and also help with discontinuation of
antibiotics it can help in identifying
resistance genes or markers that may
predict antibiotic treatment failure can
help with determining virulence factors
identifying antibiotic susceptibility to
help predict which antibiotics may be
most effective to treat the infection
distinguishing between viral and
bacterial causes infection and can be
used some of them at the point of care
so for rapid diagnostic testing it
actually is most effective if it's
implemented with antibiotic stewardship
and if an antibiotic stewardship program
is in place this is helpful because
you'll have somebody to follow up on the
results of the rapid tests quickly so an
intervention from the stewardship team
is crucial for providing interpretation
of these rapid diagnostic tests and
initiating action from providers on
these tests efficiently so here's just
one study that an example of the use of
a rapid diagnostic test with antibiotic
stewardship this study looked at Molly
Toth and stewardship intervention in
patients with pneumonia
or bacteremia due to absentee no bacter
when they compared 66 patients before
the intervention 253 patients after the
intervention and they found
significantly reduced time to effective
antimicrobial therapy by 41 days
increased clinical cure by 19%
they also decreased the length of stay
by two whole days and all of this there
was no increase in 14 day mortality and
then also they looked at costs which
didn't been significantly decrease but
they did show decrease in costs as well
just for the small number of patients
they looked at excuse me
so now I'll move on to looking at the
evidence we have for stewardship
programs in preventing antibiotic
resistance so the number of studies have
shown that there is a high correlation
between resistance to antibiotics and
their previous use antibiotics
stewardship programs have consist
consistently demonstrated to decrease
antibiotic use so would it make sense
but since we're decreasing antibiotic
use we would also be able to decrease
resistance or slow the emergence of
resistance however the studies that have
actually assess the impact of
stewardship programs on resistance have
been quite limited at this time so again
stewardship programs are broadly
considered important strategies in
mitigating the global problem of
antibiotic resistance we have good data
to support the effect of stewardship
interventions and reducing our
antibiotic use and antibiotic costs but
we have only limited data to show the
effect of interventions on reducing or
at least slowing the emergence of
antibiotic resistance a recent review of
221 studies on antibiotic stewardship
interventions only 20 of those actually
assess the impact of antibiotic
stewardship programs on antibiotic
resistance
there was a Cochrane review that looked
to estimate the effectiveness and safety
of interventions to improve antibiotic
prescribing in hospital in patients
this was done in 2017 and they looked at
20 interrupted time series studies and
they actually found that there was very
low evidence for stewardship
interventions on reducing infections
resistant infections due to
gram-negative bacteria and gram positive
bacteria but they did show good evidence
for stewardship in decreasing c diff
infections another review this one is a
systematic review that was published in
2018 looked to analyze the role of
stewardship programs specifically in
reducing bacteria resistant to
antibiotics in the hospital setting
they included 26 studies from 2012 to
2017 and so the two most appropriate
study of designs for evaluating the
impact of stewardship programs are
randomized controlled trials and are
quasi experimental studies that are
controlled so this we have a pre period
compared to a post period after the
stewardship intervention those are
considered to be the best study designs
only eight studies then their review
actually had this blog on experimental
design and there were no randomized
controlled trials the other problem with
these studies is that they Anna my onyx
stewardship program strategies that were
implemented so IV DPO conversions the
escalations
those type of things they all different
quite a bit throughout the studies and
then the different micro organism
antibiotic hairs that were evaluated
varied widely between the studies only
MRSA appeared in the great portion of
his studies that appeared in 12 out of
the 26 studies they reviewed so again
they found great heterogeneous
heterogeneity between the studies and
this limited their ability to make
conclusions
and to pool the results but looking at
the different studies they were able to
show that only 27% of those studies so
seven studies showed clearly positive
results in decreasing antibiotic
resistance so they concluded that there
was no solid evidence that stewardship
programs have in reducing antibiotic
resistance and hospital sendings so they
really called for more studies to be
conducted more high quality studies to
study this issue our stewardship program
was actually one of the studies they
looked at in that review and we
published this study in 2016 in PLoS ONE
looking at the impact of our stewardship
program which again is more prospective
audit and feedback program and we looked
at resistance in addition to a number of
different patient outcomes
so our stewardship program at the
Providence VA is a prospective audit and
feedback programming program meaning
that we review all inpatient antibiotic
use both oral and intravenous daily from
Monday to Friday our ID pharmacy fellows
residents and students review all
patients who are on antibiotic therapy
and then we make recommendations to our
ID position together we determine if we
want to go forward and make those
recommendations to the team and then if
we feel we want to make the
recommendation we'll communicate that to
the primary team kicking up taking care
of the patient via either telephone call
or a note in the chart and then we will
follow up on those interventions to
determine whether they were accepted or
not so the study that we did was we
compared a pre intervention period the
first year of our program was compared
to the pre intervention period which was
also a year long and we looked at a
number of different outcomes in
particular we looked at resistance and
so for our findings for our grande
positive or
antibiotic combinations we found no
significant changes and for our gram
negatives we found again no significant
changes except for clogged pneumo wish
there were some increases in resistance
so this may seem like some negative
results but our trends for our
resistance our grand negatives have been
increasing so it was impressive than
just the first year of our program we
only saw increases in resistance in one
organism that we looked at so that
brings us to the end and just in summary
our bacteria are now resistant to
multiple classes of antibiotics we don't
have many new antibiotics and drug
development so we really need to
preserve the antibiotics that we have
left and utilize antibiotic stewardship
principles to improve the way we use
antibiotics and so now I would like to
open it up if anybody has any questions
thank you dr. Avenue for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
I will address some some of the most
commonly asked questions by our viewers
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on the
ask a question drop-down box located on
the far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button our speaker will follow up
with your questions via email all right
let's get started
our first question is what were some of
the most common types of interventions
made by your antibiotic stewardship
program in the first year after
implementation and have these changed
now that the program has been running
over five years great yeah so our
interventions have changed in the
beginning we're making some more of the
low level that column the low-lying
fruit interventions making a lot of
recommendations for IV takeo conversions
making recommendations for vancomycin
dosing and dosing of other
microbials getting levels up or drugs in
particular trap levels or our vancomycin
so those type of low level interventions
and those made up probably the majority
of our interventions at that time and
since that time we've looked at our
interventions and trying to improve some
of more the higher level interventions
and things that may be a little bit
harder to get providers to accept such
as duration of a therapy and getting
them to get patients discontinued off
their antibiotics in a more shorter
amount of time and we actually have been
able to do that we compared our
interventions in 2014 which was one of
the first years tour of our program to a
later year 2016 and we found that in
2016 we were making quite a bit more
intervention throughout the year we're a
smaller facility so at that time we were
making about like 600 interventions a
year compared to around 400 and 2014 and
we found the greatest increase in our
interventions was actually in making
recommendations for discontinuation and
duration so those made up about 16% of
the interventions in 2014 and almost 30%
in 2016 and we found that providers are
more likely to just switch patients I
need a Pio they've learned throughout
our program we do a lot of education to
just kind of do some of those more lower
level interventions automatically now
and we don't have to make interventions
for that type of thing okay and our
second question is besides antibiotic
resistance
what were the other outcomes assessed to
measure the impact of your antibiotic
stewardship program great yeah so
resistance was just one of the aspects
we looked at we did a six point
evaluation which was kind of unique to
our study a lot of studies have just
focused on antibiotic use and making see
what the impact of their program is
there but we looked at antibiotic use we
looked at clinical outcomes such as
mortality resistance and about it costs
and so antibiotic use was the primary
outcome we looked at and we found that
broad-spectrum antibiotic use increased
our use of fluoroquinolones decrease our
anti suna modal agent use also decreased
sort since our antibiotic use decreased
it makes sense our antibiotic costs also
decreased they decreased about 14% from
the pre to the post period and this
again is just antibiotic cost so it
doesn't take into account anything else
like nurses time hanging the antibiotics
pharmacy cost making the antibiotics
that type of thing we also looked at a
shin Se t outcomes so we looked cdf
rates pre and post and we have a very
low level of c tip to have great
infection control at the Providence VA
as well so we didn't make any
significant changes there but our rate
did stay low
we also looked at a vert drug events
those didn't decrease from the pre to
the post period like I said we also
looked at patient outcomes so we looked
at mortality which didn't change between
the two periods and then we had a trend
toward a decreased length of stay and we
looked at readmission rates as well
which didn't change between the two time
periods all right and we are gonna ask
one more question what are some
recommendations for facilities looking
to start an antibiotic stewardship
program so one of the most important
things is to look at your own data so
antibiotic use and resistance data to
try to identify
of need or problem areas within your
institution and then target those that
helps to give you a goal and things to
look at when you're looking to measure
the impact of your program you can also
look to see if what you're you look to
improve is actually improving working
needs to make tweaks to your program
also there are a lot of great resources
out there for programs looking to start
a new stewardship intervention there's
both of the IDSA guidelines both in 2007
and 2016 which are helpful then the cdc
also has their core elements documents
which are also very helpful and they
have specific documents that hospitals
can use outpatient facilities long-term
care facilities for example that can be
used and they can implement some of
those core strategies that the cdc
recommends alright well I would like to
once again thank dr. Avenue for her
presentation I would also like to thank
Lavery's for making today's educational
webcast possible now before we go I want
to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through December of 2018 you
will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event that's
all for now thank you for joining us and
we hope to see you again soon goodbye